Dear Fellow Scholars, I'd like to draw your
attention to The Witness, which is a computer
game that helps you improve your scientific
thinking and reasoning skills.
It is a first person game and if you like
solving puzzles, well, it has them in abundance.
Before we start, I'd like to note for transparency,
that if you're worried about spoilers, everything
shown in this video is taken from the first
5 to 10 minutes of the game. Also, this is
not a sponsored video, I am not paid for any
of this, I am just absolutely spellbound by
this game. After completing it, I felt that
I learned so much, and felt so much smarter,
which is something that I did not feel playing
through any other game. I remember that I
felt sorry after beating every single puzzle
as there was less and less left from the game.
I just absolutely love how this game approaches
the concept of teaching. It never says a word,
it guides you by creating appropriate puzzles
for you to overcome. It teaches without teaching.
First, we're shown that we have to reach the
exit from a starting point. However, there
is many different ways of doing that, so to
keep it challenging, we have to put constraints
on the problem. It seems that these white
and black blocks have to be in separate regions.
We now have seemingly the same puzzle, but
we realize that by changing something as simple
as the position of the exit, our previous
plans fall apart, and we often have to think
outside of the box to overcome these new challenges.
I see an empty block over there. Who knows
how it will react if I lock it together with
a white block? There is an opportunity to
try it. For educational purposes, I'll ignore
it for now.
Another slightly changed puzzle, another time
when we need a complete redesign.
This series of puzzles beautifully displays
how the slightest change to a problem can
require us to completely rethink our approach.
In this last puzzle, we need to use these
empty blocks to create one big region with
all the white markers. We had the opportunity
to learn about the empty blocks before, but
even if we missed it, the game makes sure
we understand this concept by the end of this
challenge. Beautiful design.
These were, of course, tutorial-level educational
puzzles from the very start of the game. Later,
the search space will be too large to just
guess randomly, so we have to systematically
put constraints on the problem and eliminate
a large number of solutions. If we do this
more and more we inevitably end up with the
right solution.
This is exactly the kind of thinking that
is required for scientific breakthroughs.
Some of the teachings really remind me of
the book by the name The Art of Learning by
Josh Waitzkin. He discussed that improvement
in almost any field comes by challenging and
overcoming dogma. Dogma means a set of principles
that are so deeply entrenched in our minds
that we take them for granted and are unable
to challenge them. For example, in karate,
fighting on the ground is deemed to be not
honorable, therefore they don't practice it.
A wrestler would exploit this weakness, and
use it to his advantage and smash them into
the ground.
The author of the book defeated his opponents
in chess and martial arts by not only finding
out their dogma, but inserting dogma into
their heads and using it against them.
One great example of that in martial arts
is when you are facing a weaker opponent who
pushes you. If you didn't want to, you could
remain unwavering, but what is even better
is pretending to move when he pushes you.
After a few times, your opponent will be undoubtedly
sure that when he pushes you, you will move.
And in the decisive moment, when he pushes,
you will remain still and in balance, and
counterattack. Your opponent will be swiftly
defeated and won't have any idea what really
happened. This book is such a great read,
check it out.
The Witness often tries to do the same. It
inserts dogma in your head without you noticing
it, and will ask you to break through it to
overcome new challenges. And it does it in
the most beautiful way I have seen.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!